[Musique]
dans le fond j'étudie l'interaction
entre les trous noirs supermassifs au
centre des galaxies et leur
environnement plus particulièrement dans
les amas de galaxie et dans certains cas
si la galaxie est assez massive comme la
Voie Lactée par exemple elles vont
contenir un trou noir super massif dont
la masse dépasse un million de fois la
masse du Soleil certains de ces trous
noirs là vont émettre des Getes
particules très puissants des particules
qui vont aller très rapidement qui vont
être injecté au-delà de la G haute si
cette galaxie là se trouve au centre
d'un amo de galaxie contenant des
centaines à des milliers de galaxies ben
les G vont venir interagir avec le gaz
qui se trouve entre les galaxies c'est
un gaz très chaud qui peut atteindre des
millions de degrés celus et qu'on peut
observer avec des télescopes rayon X
j'ai effectu mes recherches grâce à des
observatoires comme l'Observatoire very
large aray au nouveau- meexique un
réseau de 27 antennes qui capte la
lumière radio des jet des trous noirs
supermassifs j'utilise également des
télescopes spatials comme le télescope
CHRA qui observe la lumière rayon X moi
je me spécialise dans les AM mod
galaxies voisins qui sont pas très loin
relativement pas très loin comme la mode
percée qui se trouve à peu près à 250
millions d'années lumière d'ici on
comprend mal l'interaction entre les
jets et le milieu qui se trouve entre
les galaxies et mes observations vont
permettre de mieux caractériser cette
interaction là puisqu'on peut vraiment
voir les détails de qu'est-ce qui se
passe dans ces
[Musique]
objetsl y